Western High School. Our
officers responded to the east
parking lot at dismissal time
as students were actively
leaving the school and getting
on school buses. A car was
observed at a high rate of
speed entering the parking lot.
Our officers ordered that
vehicle to stop. It continued
south through the parking lot.
Did a U turn, headed back north
in the parking lot at a high
rate of speed. The vehicle
struck a student who were happy
to say is not injured,
seriously, and then continued
at a high rate of speed towards
our officers. Our officers gave
orders for the vehicle to stop.
One of the officers pulled his
service weapon, fired rounds at
the which then continued
towards him, made a right turn,
and then exited the parking
lot. Sometime later, two
juveniles were taken by their
family members. one to UMC, and
one to Sunrise Hospital for
non-life threatening injuries
but again, they're being
treated right now. So, I don't
have any information as the
extent of their injuries. Clark
County School District Police
Department was aided by the
University Police Department
which are also here at the
Western property as well as
officers from the Las Vegas
Metropolitan Police Department.
Las Vegas Metropolitan Police
Department Fit Team is
conducting the investigation
into this officer-involved
shooting in 72 hours. They will
brief our command staff and our
investigators as to their
findings and then we will set
up in time to do a further
briefing for all media which
will possibly be Monday. Okay?
Are these juveniles students at
Western High School? Uh no,
they are not. Possibly one was
assigned to Western High School
with the others were not and
the two people that were sent
to the I think leave UNC
Hospital Are they the
individuals in the in the car
that was being chased by CCSD
PD? Yes, it was being attempted
at the officers were attempting
to stop. Were the weapons
discharged in the parking lot
on the school campus or on
Bonanza? It was in the parking
lot on the campus. Any injuries
resulting directly from the the
officers No, none of our
officers were injured during
this this encounter. And and no
noone was hit by the the
service, the rounds that were
shot by there. Uh it appears
that the two person, two
persons that were in the
vehicle were struck by gunfire.
You know, they're conditioned.
No, we do not. We just know
that they're being treated at
those two different hospitals.
We would know if the individual
struck by the car was struck
intentionally. Uh it appears
that she was hit as the car was
fleeing through the parking
lot, not an intended target but
you know, officers were yelling
for the students that were in
the parking lot to get out of
the way, get out of the way,
and one of this unfortunately,
a student was struck. So, the
the people that were
hospitalized, they were the
suspect juveniles. They were
the vehicles. Yes, they were in
the car. Yes, that that struck
the student. Was the student
that was hit by the car? Were
they hospitalized at all? I do
not believe so. Did it seem
like those struck and those
driving the car knew each other
at all? We don't know that.
Alright, folks. Thank you.
Okay. Thank you. Alright, like
I said, 72 hours. We'll have
our briefing from Metro and
then we'll send out a release
to everyone as far as what
we'll release further
information. Thank you. Thank
you. Thank you. And now
Hillary